PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hi, I'm Priyanka.
And today, I'm
going to illustrate
the ways in which AI powers
no-code application development
for citizen developers, like
you, using Google Cloud's
AppSheet.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Organizations around the
globe have a current set
of systems and processes
that are performed manually,
but would greatly benefit
from customized digitization.
The desire to digitize is
often stopped before it begins
due to lack of resources.
To take it a step
further, it's even harder
to implement beneficial
capabilities, like AI, to make
your business workflows
smarter and more impactful.
But AI can be expensive.
Between overhead,
sourcing rare talent,
and implementing a
new infrastructure,
finding a solution that
meets all the needs
of your organization
can be challenging.
So how do you find
a solution that
can help drive
digital transformation
with the goodness of AI?
Google Cloud's no-code
platform AppSheet
is an intelligent platform
that enables anyone
to be both an app
creator and an AI expert,
no matter their background.
What makes this possible?
A combination of baked-in
machine learning and Google's
AI in action.
These allow app creators to
simplify the app creation
process by interpreting user's
intent with the AppSheet
Editor, make their app more
powerful and efficient,
engage with your data
and users in new ways.
What does this
look like exactly?
Smart Assistant behaves
like Google Assistant
inside your app and customized
to your business domain.
Using natural language,
it searches your data
based on how the
model is trained.
Can you show me inspections
from last month?
Another AI capability is
Optical Character Recognition,
known as OCR, which
extracts data from images.
Here's an example of that.
In this inspection app, we've
already done some pre-work
by training our data
model to identify
what we should be extracting.
We'll start a new entry by
clicking on New Inspection,
and can now add a new
image to this form.
We'll upload a new
image to the app,
and we can now see that the form
has been automatically filled
with the data from the image.
The takeaway from
all this is that you
don't have to be an expert
to use the algorithms that
provide these opportunities.
We provide no-code interfaces
that allow anyone the ability
to create their custom
machine learning models
for their particular
business domain.
And because these algorithms are
built on top of Google Cloud AI
features, you get the
same powerful machine
learning capabilities
that were traditionally
only available to trained
software engineers,
without writing any code at all.
Whether you're trying
to find an inventory
item using Smart
Assistant in your app,
or taking pictures of
asset tags in the field,
there's countless opportunities
for improving your team's
efficiency with AppSheet.
Ready to start building
your apps with AI?
Get started today by
clicking this link.
Happy app building.